everybody I would like to take this
moment to say big hello to all of our
servicemen and women stationed overseas
around the world and to
and to all of the families here waiting
for the safe return home our thoughts
are with you when we thank you and now
ladies and gentlemen please welcome mr.
Tom Hanks
that's a snappy tone
what's the name of it again hey hey
everybody how do you sum up an 80-year
show business career in just a few
sentence well I gotta tell you it's
almost as difficult as trying to
describe all the affection and respect
and all the admiration and love we have
for mr. Bob Hope
I gotta tell you he was a radio star mr.
Bob Hope was a vaudeville legend a giant
on television and certainly a hero to
millions of our soldiers when we visited
overseas in worn piece over the decades
from 1939 to 1977 he hosted this very
show a record 18 times and I gotta tell
you we have so many memories to thank
him for these are some of the best
good evening ladies and gentlemen
welcome to you got your career this is
the night devoted to one man óskar or as
he's known around my house
the fugitive good evening and welcome to
the real star wars or as as it's known
at my house passover of course there was
a rumor going around last year that i
might win an oscar but nobody paid any
attention to it so i stopped spreading
not only wasn't i nominated on hollywood
boulevard to just put a manhole cover
over my star tonight we set aside petty
differences forget old feuds and start
new ones I hope you losers aren't too
disappointed there's a bright side to
all this remember you can still run for
governor fourth time here I come here
every year for my attack of indigestion
but I'm here again for my annual
exercise in masochism this is the 27th
annual Academy Awards now 10 to the 47th
Annual Academy Awards I think they ought
to give me an Oscar just for attendance
don't you I didn't do the show last year
didn't you watch him a show without me I
want a change well I'm gonna send it I
love him
they all have their Oscars but are they
happy
may I present you with the Oscar this is
an Oscar I've never really wanted an
Oscar although I guess they are
reassuring to an actor who doesn't know
how great he really is
I know what to say I don't have riders
from this type of work
when we return Ben Stiller Owen Wilson
and Liv Tyler on the 76th annual Academy
Awards